let's get to audience questions for the
week one that in many forms has been on
a lot of people's minds which I am sort
of consolidating into one question is is
this the start of a new global recession
and the answer is maybe we don't know
and as I've told you before economists
and people in general are very very bad
at Purdue at predicting the economy in
general here's what we do know and here
here are a few thoughts on this number
one the system we have has booms and
busts that goes back a very long time so
every year that we don't have a bust we
don't have a downturn we are a year
closer to the next downturn I've been
saying this since 2014 something like
that on the program there were people
predicting it would be in 2016 there
were people predicting it would be in
2017 I've never predicted exactly when
it would be I've said at some point
there is going to be a downturn right
now we find ourselves in this very
precarious situation with multiple
record downturns and then erratic sort
of partial recoveries in the stock
market the stock market is not the
economy but certainly when you are
looking at you know that multiple
thousand point swings in a single day
one way or the other that is a sign that
we have a very fragile situation number
two the virus stuff of course and what
you're now seeing that I think is
actually going to lead to a positive
conversation in a sense in the middle of
really bad things going on people losing
money out of the retirement accounts
people getting sick with the virus
oil prices all over the place Trump
trying to frame this battle around oil
prices as good for Americans because
it'll make gas cheaper personally I
would rather not lose 15% in two weeks
out of my retirement account then you
know 20 cents less per gallon of gas
maybe that's because I don't drive
around that much for some people maybe
the other the gas prices are more
impactful everybody's situation is
different but this if we are seeing the
beginning of a global recession what's
really important to understand is that
while it may have been triggered by a
combination of the virus causing fears
and panic selling which then leads to
company's downward revising profit
estimates which makes more selling
happen which drops the stock market more
which eliminates a lot of money and
liquidity that could be available for
businesses to expand and it causes this
self-fulfilling prophecy so the virus
profit all this stuff is tied in that
may indeed be what we consider triggers
what is going on right now or what may
be happening but it doesn't change the
underlying fragility of the system I
spoke about this earlier when you have
an economy that has I don't remember
offhand the number it's like half of the
US population can't afford an unexpected
$400 expense or maybe it was 40% can't
afford a thousand it's something like
that right that is a fundamentally
fragile situation so when you have a
president bragging about wages are up
1.5 percent or whatever the case may be
that doesn't change if cost-of-living is
up that people are living on the edge
people are living paycheck to paycheck
when you have a tax reform plan done
where the lion's share of the tax
savings go to people who are already
fine and have no real need to spend any
more money to the very very rich rather
than the lion's share of the dollars
going to people who actually are
depending on their earned income and
wages to fund their lifestyles which are
not extravagant by the way you have a
fragile situation you have the wealthy
accumulating more at the same time that
you have people who are living paycheck
to paycheck barely any better off that's
an inherently fragile situation so of
course when you have something like the
virus stock market crash company saying
we don't think we're gonna make as much
this year as we thought so we're gonna
revise our estimates downward that
crashes the stock price we might have to
lay people off then those employees
without a job can't go out and buy
things it is a it is a self-perpetuating
feedback loop okay so if this is the
beginning of the global recession maybe
the virus is making it happening a year
sooner than it otherwise would or two
years sooner or whatever the fundamental
fragility of this economic system that
we have which is a less regulated for
of capitalism than some of the northern
European countries is the way I would
describe what we have in the United
States that has not changed and it's
always a matter of well when is the next
pullback going to happen and what will
trigger it rather then have we really
reorganized the economy to prevent this
from happening at all have we for
example used a higher marginal tax rate
on the very rich to raise the standard
of living for the greatest number of
people so that maybe instead of half the
country being unable to afford an
unexpected four hundred dollar expense
you reduce that to only ten percent of
the country is unable to afford an
unexpected five hundred dollar expense
that strengthens the economy
significantly rich people having more
money in their bank account that they're
not planning to spend anyway does not
strengthen the economy at the broad
level that is one thing that is very
quickly being exposed here this doesn't
minimize the virus the reality of the
virus this doesn't minimize any of the
other things the oil prices all of this
other stuff but that is what I think we
should be focusing on which is if it is
the start of the new global recession it
was merely a matter of time and until
the system has changed to be less
fragile and to have fewer people living
precariously on the edge of being able
to afford their not extravagant
lifestyles we're always just another
year or two or a few years from the
exact same thing happening it's it's a
it's a feature of the system not a bug
and more and more economists seem to
understand this